mon café il est où mon café [ __ ]
ah ben voilà
[Applaudissements]
savatier ouais ça va trois bonjour
bonjour qui vont devient je présente le
stagiaire dans salut les terriens cette
saison voilà je suis le seul à canal+ à
avoir dans mon contrat une clause qui
m'autorise à me [ __ ] de la gueule de
thierry ardisson
je peux me moquer de tous enfin source
de son physique son âge de cannabis sa
femme ses enfants
et son poignet de force voilà maintenant
j'ai carte blanche vous êtes sûr je peux
pas faire de vagues sur le poignet de
force que c'est vrai quand on fait pas
de muscu et pas de moto c'est ridicule
alors bon pour prendre prochaine petit
débrief rapide quand même sur l'émission
de la semaine dernière thierry je vous
le dis je suis très très déçu parce que
la semaine dernière on a reçu véronique
sanson oui moi je me suis vraiment cassé
le cul pour lui faire une loge aux
petits oignons voilà franchement ce
serait cru chez nicolas un non mais
c'est vrai je me 82 qu'est ça m'a coûté
trois séances doceo cette connerie et la
meuf elle a touché à rien du tout [ __ ]
par contre nous à déglinguer le stock de
san pellegrino ça c'est parti du coup
par contre avec le stockage l on peut
recevoir renault quand vous voulez
cette semaine c'est un très très beau
plateau thierry félécitations emmanuel
petit qui vient nous voir pour son livre
francs tireurs alors comme vous l'a
demandé j'ai fait le le résumé de son
livre voilà il est juste là
c'est isabelle mergault qui vient de
voir pour sa pièce de théâtre un qui
revient isabelle c'est bien parce
qu'elle s'est attiré le public jeune au
théâtre puisqu'elle joue avec sylvie
vartan bien
philippe etchebest
pas de vanne sur philippe etcheverry non
je te tue peu en berne oui je peux non
j'ai envie de rester en vie non mais
c'est vrai déjà quand un mec rate une
piémontaise il se fait défoncer aussi
fait une boulette moi j'ai envie de voir
grandir mes gosses à la limite je
préfère m'en prendre à claude bartolone
bah oui quand même je veux dire en train
contrôle fiscal et il me retrouver entre
quatre planches de sapin le choix il est
vite fait vous connaissez l'adage plaie
d'argent n'est pas mortelle peut-être
mais plaie ouverte peut s'infecter
d'ailleurs claude bartolone vous
connaissez les gens un peu bien placé et
où danse à ce que je vous explique moi
je vais en fait je recherche un logement
je vis dans 1 9 mètre carré c'est la
galère il était dans quelle
circonscription thiery avant que le
bartolome 9 3 a laissé le roi du nas 3
vous emmerdez pas ça va
bush est ce parce que vous loupez
maintenant mesdames et messieurs je suis
ici pour vous poser les questions trop
con que thierry n'a pas voulu vous posez
on va commencer avec isabelle mergault
isabelle ou jouez votre pièce avec
sylvie vartan au théâtre des variétés
qui à deux pas du musée grévin c'est
pour que sylvie vartan puisse rentrer
plus vite chez elle
claude bartolone
ça vous embête pas d'être le seul à ne
pas pouvoir dormir l'assemblée nationale
à l'assemblée nationale ce sont des
vieux qui dorment sur des banquettes en
velours rouge du coup michel drucker il
vous a fait un procès ou pas encore
emmanuel petit vous êtes connu pour être
l'écorché vif du football français vous
savez que si vous aviez été dans la
chanson française vous auriez été
francis lalanne vous avez là
philippe etcheveste vous connaissez
l'adage avec les humoristes femme qui
rit à moitié dans son lit du coup pour
les cuisiniers c'est quoi ces femmes
repus à moitié dans le sens que
je vais y aller merci beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus